yeah
muhammadi is speaking to her twin sister
elahe who's been in prison since
September 29th elahe was arrested
shortly after attending the funeral of
Masa amini the young woman who died in
police custody Elohim muhammadi is one
of 95 reporters detained in nearly nine
months
many have been released on bail elahe is
not one of them her desk at the hammihan
newspaper offices is just as she left it
only now she is in the headlines
Ella is charged with cooperating with
the Hostile government of the United
States acting against National Security
and spreading propaganda Against The
Establishment her trial will be held
behind closed doors if convicted she
could face up to 10 years in jail
she has denied these charges and we are
waiting to see what evidence will be
presented in court we hope she will be
acquitted and compensated for this very
difficult time she has endured
fellow journalists nilu farhamadi took
the photo inside the hospital when amini
died she is one of four journalists from
the reformers newspaper shark who was
arrested
ufr is facing the same charges as
elohead and she too is still in prison
her editor is worried
the main problem in Iran is that the
authorities make decisions arbitrarily
when a journalist reports on an issue
not in line with the officials they come
after you media is the first Target of
the authorities when the reporting is
not what they want
but officials say they broke the law
foreign
journalistic activities in line with the
law of free in Iran the head of the
Judiciary repeatedly said we support
journalism but journalists activities
should not go against the law the
Constitution guarantees media Freedom as
long as journalists do not endanger the
Islamic Republic offend the supreme
leader and do not spread false
information it leaves plenty of room for
interpretation and subjective censorship
that's something that Tehran branch of
the association of Iranian journalists
is trying to fight it says in recent
months Iran has had the highest number
of imprisoned journalists in the last 30
years making this country one of the
most difficult places in the world for
reporters
dorsa Jabari Al Jazeera Tehran